ja also die uhr hat ja nachdem russland
die ukraine überfallen hat riesiges
aktionspakete auf den weg gebracht und
das ausdrückliche ziel dieser sanktionen
war putin unter druck zu setzen seien
verbrecherischen krieg zu beenden und
ich finde langsam ist es zeit der
wahrheit ins gesicht zu sehen und
festzustellen diese sanktionspolitik ist
leider komplett gescheitert sie hat
dieses ziel nicht nur nicht erfüllt
sondern sie wirkten in die andere
richtung sie ruiniert uns nicht russland
und vor allem die russischen einnahmen
also der staatshaushalt dem man
eigentlich treffen wollte die sind höher
ist je zuvor weil die hohen preise
natürlich obwohl man weniger verkauft
letztlich bei putin mit zusätzlichen
einnahmen zu buche schlagen und ich muss
ja wenn man das konstatiert da kann man
doch nicht sagen wir machen so weiter
und auch das ganze gerede über
alternative lieferanten für öl für gas
das war doch heiße luft
[Musik]